episode 7 got me like
[Music]
yep I think I found something even more
depressing than Thanksgiving with my
family house of the Dragon episode 7 has
arrived with all the dragon riding and
incest you've come to expect so let me
take you down this non-spoiler deep dive
into the episode its connection to Game
of Thrones and if you're lucky you may
even get to marry your own bug
collecting sister and she eats bugs
these intros don't make any sense but
you should like And subscribe anyway
I'll be coming out with the next episode
preview breakdown very soon if you
happen to watch my last video you'll
have seen some of the huge changes
between the episodes two to five intro
credits and episode 6. so me being the
absolute insane person that I am decided
to look frame by frame to see if there
were any changes between six and seven
and slap my butt and call me Damon there
sure is it's so small I barely caught it
but unlike the episode 6 version Episode
7 has lanor's emblem spewing out blood
this has been an effect reserved only
for characters who have died like Queen
Emma so it makes sense this happens for
laner for in this episode he is presumed
dead even though he's now living his
best life across the narrow sea in San
Francisco whereas episode 6 started with
the sounds of childbirth episode 7
starts with the ocean where at driftmark
the ancestral home of house valarian the
stone cast skit of Lena valarian who
ordered her Dragon Veigar to burn her
last episode is prepared to be dropped
into the sea valarian custom whereas the
targaryens burn their dead like we saw
with Emma and baby Balon in episode 1.
The valoreans Returned them to the Sea
her tomb is dropped into the water where
there are several others around
conducting the ceremony is Corliss
valarian's brother Raymond who also
joined Corliss and Lenor in the battle
for the stepstones in the book vehemond
is corliss's nephew but they've changed
it to brother for the show one of the
things I loved about this episode was
how director Miguel sapochnick who also
directed famous Game of Thrones episodes
like Battle of the bastards shot these
small glances between characters take
for example this one between vaymond and
Damon vehman was pretty much ready to
Mutiny against demon when they fought
together in the stepstones Lena's body
is brought back to the Merlin King the
god of the narrow sea whom it is said
gave the valarians the Driftwood throne
and the whole gang is here from lorus
the rat and even Otto Hightower who is
once again handed the King after Lionel
strong was fired you may have noticed
this line from vaman where he talks
about valarian blood runs thick then
looks sharply at Jason Luke he knows
they're not really lanor's kids and when
he says their blood must never run thin
Damon lets out a laugh it looks as
though some salt is thrown on the casket
as it's launched into the water an egg
on here looks just about as bored as he
was watching Jace tame his Dragon just
make sure not to give him a room with an
open window there are also five dragons
in this particular shot we have
Rainier's Cyrax this Dragon who is
either dream fire or Melise Damon's
caraxis laner sea smoke and this little
guy who I'm guessing by his size and
proximity to the wake below is bayla's
Dragon Moon Dancer who is said to have
been pale green with pearl horns we also
know from this shot later in the episode
as the king's ship to parts that three
dragons are from Allison's children
Veigar dream fire and aegon's dragon who
we haven't really seen yet Sunfire and
just as Rainier walked into the Hunting
Party of episode 3 alone so too does she
hear there are so many interesting power
dynamics going on We Have Allison giving
Rainier the look of this [ __ ] look
while Leonard takes a completely normal
dip in the sea Corliss will later tasks
her Carl Corey with retrieving his lover
who is really making a drunken fool of
himself speaking of drunks no not me
there's aegon II slamming back wine like
me during frosh week we learned that he
is betrothed to his own sister Helena I
guess Rainier's proposal to wet her son
Jace to Helena was rejected aegon isn't
too pleased with this Arrangement his
sister is weird and plays with bugs all
the time but Eamon said he'd totally
bang his sister if it meant doing his
duty and strengthening the family
rhaenyra seeing that Lena's children are
all alone asked Jace to say something
nice to his cousins but he too is also
mourning he lost his true father sir
Harwin strong to that fire at harrenhal
this is a fire Rainier will later
attribute to a curse word is said that
since the time of aegon the Conqueror
countless houses have met their end
there under mysterious circumstances if
you go to the Ice and Fire Wiki you can
see just how many strange things have
happened there over time in this
particular case we know it wasn't a
curse that caused this fire rather Laura
Strong's tongueless men that just sounds
like a really bad porno raniera
essentially tells Jace to suck it up the
valorians are their kin and the strongs
are not I found it to be a pretty
callous thing for a woman who just lost
her baby daddy Jace will eventually go
over to his cousins and doesn't have to
say a word just his presence is a small
Comfort speaking of something that's not
comfortable Lars staring at Allison like
the guy who won't leave you alone at the
bar sir Kristen tells us that he's the
new Lord of harrenhal so it seems his
motive Innovation for killing his own
father and brother wasn't purely driven
by helping out the queen this was
actually one of my favorite scenes in
the episode Corliss tells Luke that
driftmark is one day to be his passing
his father Lenor who will be busy being
King consort in King's Landing and also
passing Jace who will one day be king
but Luke doesn't want it as he rightly
notes for if he's Lord of driftmark it
means everyone else is dead bonus points
for the little seahorse he plays with
rhaenis and rhaenyra don't even talk to
each other the last time we really saw
these two interact together was in
episode 2 where renise reminded her that
the realm won't allow a woman to take
the throne it's what happened to her at
the great Council when the Lords of the
realm voted in favor of viserys even
though renice had the stronger claim
hence why she is known as the queen who
never was renice also does not think too
highly of renera believing the rumors
that raniera fooled around lenor's back
and that her children are in fact Harwin
strongs Eamon and Jay share look without
words it's a bit awkward and all by
himself is the twice widowed Damon
Targaryen King viserys comes to comfort
his brother telling him that he knows
what it's like to lose someone you love
what's worse is that his children are a
spitting image of their mother both a
comforting and cursed reminder of what
he once had and lost the king entreates
demon to return to King's Landing with
his daughters where he belongs but he
says that pentos is home last episode
Damon field an offer from Prince Reggio
haratus of pentos to live a life of
luxury there in exchange for Dragon
protection this is all considering the
newly formed alliance between Dorne and
the triarchy with Damon's marriage to
Rainer at the end of the episode I think
we can safely say that's off the table
Otto here looking like me after a night
getting drunk off Bacardi Breezers he
tells Damon he's sorry for his loss
these two have had a feud since episode
1. Otto hated Damon's unruly and chaotic
nature and how he ran the city watch and
Damon had great fun teasing The Hand by
knocking his son out of the tournament
and asking for Allison's favor and it
looks as though much hasn't changed for
Damon says of Otto no matter how fat the
leech grows it always wants for another
meal as viserys makes his way to bed you
can make out this structure in the
distance I can't tell for sure but it
might be sharp point the seat of House
Bar Emin in the crownlands I'm
constantly impressed at the attention to
detail the creators of this show have
put in Port visares calls his wife by
his ex-wife's name Emma and everyone
around him is like don't say anything
Otto catches his grandson aegon passed
out along the castle walls is one of the
few times we've seen Otto lash out in
anger he's usually extremely composed
but this is not Behavior fitting of a
king this scene also serves a secondary
purpose setting up aegon as being too
drunk when the eventual Kitty brawl
takes place Eamonn the kind of loner
that he is sees vegar among the clouds
with Lena dead vegar is without a rider
we've already seen how Eamonn yearns to
claim a dragon and in this episode he
gets his chance among the dunes of
driftmark Eamon Ventures toward the
oldest and largest of the living Dragons
It's a tense scene of whether the dragon
will allow the young boy to claim him
but eventually he does in the book
things happen a bit differently it's
actually a three-year-old Prince Joffrey
the child who raniera gave birth to last
episode who catches Eamonn getting close
to the dragon and out of fear of being
caught Eamon clamors up the dragon and
by the grace of the Gods isn't burned to
death I'll get into some more of these
departures from the book in a moment
because there are some big ones
meanwhile rainy spenced her husband
about Damon Damon was the one who denied
Lena coming back to driftmark where
their maesters might have been able to
save her perhaps the gods have scorned
house valarian but the conversation soon
turns to rhaenice never getting the
crown Corliss has kept alive the idea
that she can one day get it back if not
through her than through her children
but rhaenys gave up that that idea a
generation ago corliss's desire for the
throne has nothing to do with Justice
for his wife rather his own ambition
ambition that has already cost him the
life of his child but for Corliss a
legacy is more important than blood
speaking of Legacy rhaenys wants
driftmark to pass to Lana's firstborn
Bala rather than Lenor and Luke deep
down Corliss must know Jace and Luke
aren't of true Valerian blood and
driftmark should pass to a valarian but
Corliss is set in his ways history does
not remember blood it remembers names
rhaenyra and Damon walk along the beach
it's an interesting juxtaposition to the
walk she had with her first husband
Lenor back in episode 5. instead of
walking right to left during the day
these two walk left to right at night
Rainier events that Lenor has not made
an effort to keep up appearances for
goodness sakes he was taking a dip
during his sister's wake Harwin at least
made her feel desired and although Lenor
and her tried to conceive she believes
it never worked because there was no joy
in it just another way not having a
penis has let raniera down rhaenyra
believes she never should have sent
Harwin to harrenhal because of that
curse but Damon calls [ __ ] he knows
that it was likely Otto or Allison's
doing then renera confronts Damon for
abandoning her he has a history of this
venturing off to the stepsons going to
pentos and even leaving her in the
middle of a brothel when she was just a
girl her life has been [ __ ] without him
to which he quickly reminds her his
hasn't been that great either she asks
him if he ever loved Lena to which he
replies we were happy enough I'm not
exactly sure we can take anything he
says about his love life to rhaenyra at
face value as Allison said about Damon
in episode 4 and I'm paraphrasing here
when have you ever known Damon not to
lie because nothing turns someone on
more than a funeral renera puts the
moves on her uncle and Damon's like
[Applause]
I find it pretty interesting interesting
that their lovemaking occurs among a
shipwreck a metaphor for the wreck that
is their lives Damon's back is littered
with scars from his years of battle and
I can only hope raniera doesn't have
another child or else you have some
explaining to do in the show version
It's abela and Reina along with Jace who
confront aemond after his Joyride on
vegar vegar was to be claimed by Reina
remember she dreamed of having her own
dragon after the egg cradled with her at
Birth failed to hatch but Eamon swaggers
in like the little gangster he is and
basically says you snooze you lose
fighting off all four of them like he's
in some Jackie Chan movie but things
escalate when Eamonn threatens to bash
Luke's face with a rock telling him
he'll burn in Flames just like his
father Luke doesn't know that Harwin was
his real dad and Jace trying to protect
his little bro pulls out a knife and
attacks It's Quickly tossed out of his
hand where Luke picks it up and while
Jace throws sand in eamon's face Luke
slashes out his eye commander of the
kingsguard Harold westerling comes to
the rescue and the King gathers everyone
in the throne room to go over what
happened I want to ask you a bunch of
questions
they want to have them answered
immediately he's rightly pissed that his
kingsguard weren't there to protect him
but as Sir Kristen has said they've
never had to protect princes from
princes the maester informs them that
eamon's eye is lost and Allison blames
aegon for being drunk and not there for
his brother
um Allison where were you it's pretty
sad to see how this feud between Rainier
and Allison has now rooted itself into
their children the king is told that
Jake's and Luke's legitimacy was called
into question something raniera calls
the highest of treasons but where has
Eamonn heard such slander obviously his
mother however he knows he can't rat her
out instead calling out his brother the
poor dude was just trying to nurse a
hangover aegon says a line plucked
straight out of the book regarding Jason
Luke's true parentage everyone knows
just look at them the King has heard
enough they are a family and all must
apologize and move on as their King
father and grandfather he demands it but
for Allison this is insufficient
efficient she wants a literal eye for an
eye Luke's for eamonn's even going so
far as to order sir Kristen to take it
out and give it to her I caramba the
king settles things down and all seems
good until Allison reaches for the cat's
pod dagger and attacks rhaenyra this is
a powder keg ready to go off and thank
God this didn't turn into a bloodbath
you have the king's guards not really
knowing who to protect on the one hand
you have the queen and the other the
princess who is heir to the throne and
for a moment it looks like we're in this
stalemate when anyone could have come in
and helped take Allison off the princess
Kristen was going to step in but
thankfully Damon sees to that he also
has beef with the man he once called Sir
Crispin after being defeated by him in
the tournament from episode 1. it's here
we get to see Alison Venter true
frustrations she has been nothing but
the dutiful Queen upholding her family
the law and sacrificing everything while
rhaenyra has been able to do anything
she wants having Affairs and bastard
children and raniera just saying that it
must be exhausting hiding under her
cloak of righteousness and now everyone
can see Allison for who she truly is
Allison slices Rainier's forearm and a
hush Falls among the crowd Allison
herself can't believe what she did Eamon
tells everyone that he may have lost an
eye but he gained a dragon something
Otto will later Echo saying that dragon
is worth a thousand times the price he
paid you'd think Otto would come in and
berate his daughter for what she did but
the opposite is true she has finally
shown him she has what it takes to get
aegon on that throne for years Otto has
tried to show Alison who raniera truly
is but Alison pushed back now she's out
for blood literally fortunately being
the queen has its perks she'll face no
repercussions for what she did to the
princess unfortunately for renyra she'll
have a permanent scar on her arm for the
rest of her life and look who showed up
being like so I'm late did I miss
anything and rhaenyra has the best roast
of the episode I should have been there
there should be our house words
Lenor is devastated at what has
transpired he wasn't there for his
sister his wife and hasn't been the dad
his kids deserve so he tells her he will
send away sir Carl and recommit himself
to strengthening their house and
preparing for her Ascension of course
this all happens as soon as she's made
love to her uncle the king's Entourage
leaves driftmark and the King isn't
doing so well all this stress can't be
good for a guy who basically looks like
the Crypt Keeper where is he
where is my grandson Allison tries to
apologize but he won't hear any of it
following the King's ship are three
dragons which must be aegon's Dragon
Sunfire Helena's dream fire and now
eamon's vegar rhaenyra watches them
leave telling Damon that everything they
possess is owed to fire yet fire costs
them both what they loved meaning Harwin
and Lena she tells demon she can't face
Allison and her cohort known as The
Greens alone and suggests they bind
their blood just as aegon the Conqueror
did with his sisters this means marriage
since aegon married both of his sisters
with the two of them United their claim
would not easily be challenged the only
problem is rhaenyra is still married so
Damon the ever cunning man that he is
devises a plan in the book it is said
that sir Carl Corey stabbed Lenor to
death while attending a fair in spice
town and the book even offers several
theories how this played out one was
that sir Carl had grown jealous of Lenor
after he found a new lover the other
that Damon paid him to kill Lenor in
exchange for extravagant wealth for it
was known that sir Carl had a Lord's
taste and a peasants purse the show
however paints a much more deceptive
tale Damon Pacer Carl not to kill Leonor
but Aid in faking his death first Carl
and Lenor make sure there's a witness to
this duel a young page then a decoy body
is substituted for laners while Carl and
Lenor Venture across the narrow sea to
start a new life together we even see
laner having shaved off his iconic white
hair this is a win-win for everyone
except laner's parents who now believe
both their children gone on the other
hand rhaenyra gets to take Damon as her
husband and laner gets to live his own
life on the kingship Lars creeps his way
back to Allison offering to quote
balance the scales should the queen seek
revenge for her son if there's anyone
that could make that happen it's lorus
Allison knows that lorus could be a
strong Ally telling him his devotion has
not gone by unnoticed there will be a
day when she'll need someone with his
skills and discretion meanwhile Damon
and raniera are wed in relative secrecy
with only a high priest maester and
their children in attendance not much is
known about this Valerian marriage right
only that the book describes the
ceremony as a wedding of blood and fire
this particular marriage takes place on
Dragonstone and even a blade of dragon
glass native to Dragonstone is used in
the ceremony in the book Rainier is 23
and her uncle 39. it's gonna be a little
bit suspicious when the day after your
husband was supposed easily killed you
go on and marry your uncle Rainier
actually expresses these concerns to
Damon but he's okay with it let their
enemies think they may have been
involved for it'll show that they are
not to be messed with the episode ends
with a now bald Lenor and Sir Carl Corey
venturing off to a ship in the distance
to start their new life together and
just as the episode started with the
sounds of the ocean so too does it end
with it now if you're curious what's to
happen next be sure to subscribe to my
channel because within 24 hours of
releasing this video I come out with my
next episode preview video which has
tons of book spoilers and theories on
where the show is headed next thanks for
watching everyone be sure to like And
subscribe and let me know what you
thought of the episode below for more
bad takes you can follow me on Twitter
and Instagram at thinkstoryyt until next
time remember I should have been there
there should be our house words